i have one purpose  on this earth and that is to become  a great writer  girls no  i mean at least you got to take our  courses off what are they so afraid of  maybe they're scared that if they teach  us how the world works we'll figure out  how to take over  hmm  marry me  i don't i know how long you've waited  you've grown old me old you're old the  way women dress these days is idiotic i  want to be able to sit at my desk and  fully inflate my lungs well we all have  dreams father i am a poet and there is  nothing you can do to stop me  while i'm here  i want to do something that matters it's  bigger than fame this is a very dark  time the violence the suffering that's  what i want to heal  with my poetry you need to go fetch the  water you know what  [Music]  sometimes i feel like i was born in the  wrong century  you